Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters. I just want to go over what the process to get started in our clinic is if you have interest moving forward obviously or on our website.
I highly encourage you that you look at the information and see if this is something you want to work with. We try to help people with all sorts of different conditions.
So if you want to move forward it really starts with a call. Obviously look at all the information. We got thousands of blog posts for free.
You go on our video site. We have thousands of videos for free. There's a lot of self education that can take place and we encourage you to do that.
We really feel like this is a ministry and we're trying to run our clinic like a ministry. So we're trying to help as many people as we possibly can.
But look at our plans and our fees and our costs and you can certainly call the clinic and get more information to understand what we do and what we don't do.
We don't do any in office things anymore. Everything's at a distance. Everything's over the phone. Some people love that and some people don't like that. But we have to do what God has called us to do.
And because we see people from all over the country and literally all over the world, this is just the way that we moved.
And so you can schedule a call with me. An initial call with me is called a case review. So that's your initial call with me. It's a 30 minute call and we talk over your condition, what's what's going on.
And I'll be honest if I think we can help you or or maybe you need to look elsewhere. No, regardless of what decision you make, we're going to be praying for you.
So you complete the online intake form. You can self-schedule if you want or you could call and schedule the case review call is with me. Again, it's over the phone.
We'll discuss your needs. And I'm just going to be honest with you. I'm just going to make my best recommendations. Some people I just say, hey, maybe you should just do one of our courses. I have a bunch of courses that I've created just for this because we want this to be a ministry.
We have live disease and you know, you don't have a lot of finances to work with or an autoimmune disease. Then just, you know, for $50, you could buy one of our courses and start studying.
I got tons of videos educating you through a self-help process to be able to best help yourself. So that's what that is for. For those who have cancer, we have our stop fighting cancer flagship course.
It kind of ties with my stop fighting cancer book. You can download the book on Amazon. You can buy it on Amazon. You can buy it from us.
And the courses are all online. So you can follow through with different things on the course. You can tons of videos and access to a ton of information that can help you.
If you want to come on board with us as a member slash patient, then the process is a little different. Most people start with our full membership. But again, I'll make recommendations with what is going to be best for you.
Most people contact us because of our experience with rife technology. I've been using the rife since the late 90s when, you know, my first cancer patient walked in the door with breast cancer and bilateral breast cancer, given three months to live into another 13 years.
And a big part of it was using a rife machine. So we use several different rife machines, the Atelier Robin P220 and the true rife F122 are the main machines that we use.
We have some people using other machines as well. So I'll give you my best recommendation of moving forward with the best thing for you.
We have some people that don't want to do a full membership and they can only afford a rife. We'll work with you with that. I mean, the biggest thing about a rife machine is it has to have the power to penetrate your body to give you those benefits.
So it affects the cells. And then it has to be programmed right. So all our right. We don't just sell rife machines. So we sell a rife machine program to the person.
So we don't have any ties to companies. We don't have any financial, you know, binds that keep us from recommending what we think is best for the person.
So I'll just be honest with you and tell you what I think is best and we'll try to work through that and give you what we can do to best help you.
So with our comprehensive program rather, we have weekly Zoom calls and try to teach people and makes ourselves available for questions constantly.
We're just really here to try to serve people and regardless of what you have going to know that we're here to pray for you.
So you want to take time. Look at our website. It's always free. Look at our blog posts. They're always free or YouTube channel.
Our own video channel that we created because YouTube was attacking us for a period of time. Who knows they probably will again.
But know that we're here to serve. So call us if you need as well. Again, self-schedule case review to get started and we'll walk through some ideas.
All right. As always, God bless and hopefully we'll see you soon.